the big factors from here on out are
going to be turnout
uh and uh avoiding
some of the voter suppression that
clearly donald trump
plans to do so in terms of what joe
biden can actually do
number one in the debates you've got to
avoid a big mistake if you make
the debates at this point are not going
to change many minds
unless you make a big mistake and even
then what they will likely do
is keep some people home you might have
people who are leaning biden if biden
were to make a really embarrassing
mistake during the debates i don't even
know what it would be
you could have some of those voters who
say not i'm voting for trump
but i'm going to stay home joe biden
also
must encourage early voting early in
person voting and voting absentee
we also have to remember the vaccine
surprise is coming even if it's bs we
already talked about it today
the vet the vaccine surprise is coming
in october trump will almost certainly
announce
emergency use for a vaccine we got it
even if doses aren't available for a
long time and joe biden needs to be
ready to counter out
counteract that and then what can the
democratic party do to make sure
that every absentee ballot is counted
that every melon ballot is counted
because it is quite possible this red
mirage scenario is quite possible red
mirage meaning
trump seems to be winning on election
night small margins in a few states puts
him ahead electorally
and then as the absentee ballots are
counted which are more likely to be
joe biden votes than trump votes because
biden voters are taking the virus more
seriously they're more likely to want to
vote
by mail you see the leads start to
shrink the missouri
the wisconsin lead starts to shrink
maybe the pennsylvania lead starts to
shrink
and in advance of biden taking a lead
trump deploys the lawyers
biden and democrats need a strategy so
i don't think it's as much about biden's
lead slipping
winning by seven seven weeks out from
the election
is a huge deal for me it's more about
avoiding mistakes but fighting the voter
suppression
and the vote by mail antics and the
legal
mechanisms that donald trump will use
if the democratic party were smart i
don't know if they're smart if the
democratic party were proactive
i'm not sure that they're proactive they
would have a legal strategy
with hundreds thousands of i don't know
how many lawyers you need
plenty of lawyers ready to ensure that
no court
stops the counting of absentee ballots
that is unfortunately
what this may come down to reminder
voting starts soon
illinois early voting starts 40 days
before the election that's like two
weeks from now
maine starts 30 days before the election
that's three weeks from now
michigan you can start early voting 45
days before the election that's two
weeks away
minnesota montana nebraska new jersey a
lot of these states you can start early
voting
30 to 45 days before the election the
election is now
the election is now let's not regret
this on november 4th
we've got a great bonus show for you
today remember you can get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member
instantly at joinpakman.com